if mutations were maximally random all  substitutions are equally likely I'm  showing that here this is what it would  look like if all substitutions were  equally likely but in reality transition  mutations are more common than  transversion mutations you might have  noticed that in my little cartoon  drawing here T's and C's are just  physically smaller than A's and G's  that's actually real in real life that's  the case A's and G's are larger  nucleotides than C's and T's are a  transition mutation is when a similarly  sized nucleotide gets swapped out for a  different nucleotide of the same size if  an a were is swapped out with a smaller  C that is called a transversion mutation  and it turns out that transversion  mutations are really rare this is a  physical bias it's easier for  nucleotides that are the same size to  get swapped out for each other it's just  physically easy